With all the recent political nonsense that's been going on
People are throwing the word "orwellian" around more than usual
Whether or not those concerns are founded
There's been a lot of speculation regarding just what kind of horrible future the world is headed towards
Will we really live in a dystopian society like George Orwell presented in his novel in 1984
In my opinion, probably not
But where's the fun in that?
With all the talk of Russian medelling in the recent U.S. Presidential Election
Tension between nuclear powers is brewing
Now the world has avoided nuclear war until now, but what if that were to change?
How many nuclear bombs would it take to eradicate humanity?
The last time Nuclear weapons were used in war was in 1945, on the Japanese cities of Hiroshima & Nagasaki, at the end of WWII
These bombs, dubbed Fat Man and Little Boy
Would be considered primitive by today's standards, and were actually two different types of bombs
Little Boy, the explosive that destroyed Hiroshima
Was a uranium gun-type bomb which was detonated by firing one piece of sub-critical material into another
Triggering the nuclear reaction
Fat Man was  a plutonium implosion-type bomb
Which was triggered by essentially using smaller explosives to squeeze the bomb's plutonium core
In terms of explosive power, Little Boy is estimated to have been between 12 and 18 kilotonnes of TNT
And Fat Man between 18 and 23 kilotonnes
A kiloton is the measurement of the explosive power of one-thousand tons of TNT
By comparison, a modern nuclear warhead can have a yield exceeding one megaton
And modern hydrogen bombs which I've lumped into the same catogory for this video
Can exceed 3.8 megatons which is 260 times more powerful than the explosive that destroyed Hiroshima
Even with their comparatively low yield, Little Boy and Fat Man wiped out between 113,000 and 226,000 people between them
With roughly half of those deaths occurring on the first day
With later deaths being caused by both burn, radiation sickness, and other injuries
If that kind of destructive power was packed into just 2 primitive nukes
What kind of scenario are we looking at today?
For this thought experiment, we're going to consider the standard US B83 nuclear bomb our baseline
With an explosive yield of 1.2 megatons
We're also going to give Japan a break and use my hometown of Dallas, Texas for ground zero to start the end of the world.
So, without further ado, lets blow up my neighborhood.
The estimated fatalities from dropping a 1.2 megaton nuke smack-dab in the middle of Dallas are estimated to be around
267,000 with another 649,000 injured
The initial fireball would have a radius of over a kilometer
Anything within that radius would be instantly vaporized
Moving further away from ground zero,
The air blast radius would be roughly 7 and a half kilometers
Within this range, most residential buildings would be obliterated with considerable fatalities
Even further out at the thermal radiation radius of 13.2 kilometers is where survival becomes slightly more possible
If you did manage to escape the worst of the blast, you'd still be covered head to toe in 3rd degree burns
But don't worry, you wouldn't feel it because these burns would extend through your layers of skin and destroy the nerves responsible for registering pain
Okay, so if we're looking at 300,000 dead on impact from one B83 bomb
Without taking radiation poisoning and other injuries into account
How many bombs would it take to wipe out the entire population of the massive Dallas-Fort Worth metroplex?
As of 2016, DFW had a population of about 7.1 million people
Assuming each bomb killed 300,000 people, it would take 24 bombs to eradicate every single person at once
Of course, for whoever is nuking Dallas, that would be hugely wasteful
If the bad guys wanted to kill every human on the planet at once it would take over a million bombs
Which vastly exceeds the roughly 15,000 available
And even then, many of those aren't as powerful as B83s
So they'd have to take a different approach
Instead of simply aiming for the fatalities at ground zero, the right tactic would be to take out any infrastructure and agriculture
A recent scientific report suggests that 100 nuclear detonations in a fairly short period of time
Would produce 5 teragrams, or 5 billion kilograms of soot
That would clog the Earth's stratosphere and block sunlight
Destroying much of the planet's ozone layer and triggering a drop in global temperature
That could last over 25 years
This temperature drop combined with the roughly 80% increase in ultraviolet radiation from the wrecked ozone layer
Would destroy many land and sea based ecosystems and spark a global famine
To kill 2 birds with one nuclear stone
If we were to target 100 cultural hubs and industrial areas at once
That would knock out electricity, transportation, running water, food production, communication
And would cause the long term global effects we just looked at
To make extra sure that the lethal effects of nuclear war are fully realized without going overboard
We can consider the average spread of radiation from our B83 bombs
Over the course of a week, a lethal dose of radiation can creep up to 144km from ground zero
Giving us an effective lethal range of about 65,869 square kilometers per bomb
So, if we take the total amount of land inhabited by humans
Roughly 18.6 million square kilometers and divide that by our lethal range, you're looking at 283 bombs
If everything went according to our evil plan
And we took out all the big cultural hubs around the world
That would mean that functional hospitals would be few and far between
And would be unable to treat the victims of severe burns and radiation poisoning
Over the course of the two weeks following the attack
Millions, if not billions, would die from their injuries and severe radiation poisoning
So, hypothetically speaking, it could feasibly take as few as 100 B83 bombs to knock humanity into critically endangered status
To be thorough and basically ensure extinction would take around 300
Could isolated pockets of humanity survive this nuclear winter?
Possibly. If they managed to avoid the radiation at some remote Siberian outpost and had sustainable resources
They could feasibly save the species
But it would take a long, long time to rebuild civilization as we know it
And there's your depressing speculation for the day
Go watch a cat video or something
As always, this video was intended to spark your curiosity
If you're interested in learning more about nuclear weapons and their effects, check out the links in the description
If you enjoyed this video, please take a moment to subscribe to my channel your support makes a big difference
Feel free to leave a like or a dislike as you please and let me know your thoughts in the comments below
You can watch my previous video by clicking here
Or binge watch them all by clicking here
Thanks for watching and I'll see you in the next video